je vais dire que je suis paysan super
habitués à monter sur scène mais vous
m'avez camin forcer à être là
aujourd'hui
alors j'ai pas envie de vous partager
mon histoire mois pour deux raisons
parce que n'est pas encore achevée parce
que j'ai juste envie de vous partager
l'histoire qui moi m'a permis de devenir
celui que je suis aujourd'hui
j'espère que cette histoire va vous
édifier et qu'elle va vous permettre de
de faire mieux que moi vous avez
certainement déjà vu recettes célèbre
image de quéven montrant cette jeune
fille mourante de faim devant le regard
voorhees du vautour qui attendaient
tranquillement sa mort pour se régaler
je sais pas ce qui vous inspire cette
image mais lorsque je préparais ma
communication j'ai demandé un ami ce qui
ce qu'il voyait
il m'a dit qu'il voyait l'afrique avec
tous ces mots une afrique de famine une
afrique de guerre
une afrique de souffrance une afrique de
tout ce que vous pouvez dire mémoire
lorsque je vois une image l'afrique ce
qui me vient à l'esprit c'est que chaque
image est la littérature de l'oeil du
photographe
je cherche à savoir l'histoire qui a
passé à chaque image
j'étais tout jeune quand on m'a relaté
l'histoire qui était attaché à cette
image qui était vraisemblablement proche
de la mienne avec beaucoup de différence
certainement
nous sommes en masse 1993 au soudan
quand l'or était le photojournaliste du
fao et son boulot était de tirer des
photos au matin il est sortir chercher
des photos il n'en trouvait pas parce
qu'il n'y avait plus vraiment des
personnes comme ça dans la rue c'était
que des personnes mortes de faim de
famine de soif et à un kilomètre de
marche du camp il est tombé sur cette
jeune fille
les peaux sécher agonisant sous un
soleil au zénith
l'image était déjà faute lorsque le
vautour est venu se poser juste à côté
de la jeune fille
c'était l'image du siècle une image
puissante
une image qui montre est ou le rein
qu'il y avait reçu dans toute la famille
toute la souffrance du peuple soudanais
sous le poids de la famille et sa toute
première réaction était de prendre son
appareil photo et de faire que son
cliché mais après il a continué son
chemin
la jeune fille est morte le vautour vers
son destin
elle avait 15 ans en 1993 aujourd'hui
alors à elle nourrit 4 41 ans
elles seraient certainement une mère de
famille avec trois enfants crs est mort
aujourd'hui professeur au ministre de
l'agriculture en trouver des solutions
durables pour permettre au soudan de ne
plus jamais connaître la famine
non seulement c'était d'avoir en face
d'elle juste en professionnel tu voulais
juste faire son boulot juste accompli sa
tâche
juste faire son boulot nous on m'a dit
qu'en effet comme l'était sous un
contrat sous une obligation de ne pas
intervenir au soudan face aux situations
qu'il avait sous ses yeux vous changer
le cours de l'action
donc il a respecté son contrat en effet
il devait rien faire il devait tirer que
des photos
il n'a pas faire ça c'est si et moi sauf
qu'aujourd'hui le thème de ma
communication sortie de la case en
réalité on se contente juste faire notre
boulot respecter les règles se contenter
des idées reçues on m'a dit que je
voulais juste par claire mais perd parce
qu'à un moment donné de ma vie j'ai
compris que si nous voulons changer les
choses il faut sortir de la case un
moment donné pour froisser les règles un
moment donné il faut dépasser les
limites à le moment donné il faut faire
ce qu'on ressent au plus profond de nous
parce que si notre ratio n'a pas de
l'impact sur n'ont reçu les autres on ne
l'a pas fait grand chose je sais pas si
vous avez joué ce jeu lorsque vous étiez
plus jeune - je les jouais je jouais pas
beaucoup de jeu mais ce jeu je l'aimé
bien parce qu'en effet il fallait relier
neuf points sans jamais soulever le
stylo il y avait une seule condition
pour réussir à ce jour fallait dépasser
les limites
fall est sorti de la case fallait aller
au delà des bornes
ne vous sentez de la case il faut avoir
des objectifs de grands objectifs
cet homme je laime bien j'entends
beaucoup de jeunes div j'ai envie d'être
comme mac mais mac n'a pas été mal parce
qu'il voulait juste être mac ou parce
qu'ils voulaient avoir de larges
je pense qu'il est ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui parce qu'il a voulu répondre
un problème qui touche et à la vie de
milliers de personnes
il voulait avoir de l'impact il y
compris dans l'histoire si nos actions
ne peuvent pas avoir l'impact se nouer
sur les autres on ne peut pas rentrer
dans l'histoire
on fait juste notre boulot c'est bien
d'avoir de l'impact
mais avant je voulais juste dire que que
ses histoires ses problèmes je vais dire
ses objectifs que nous nous fixons il
faut déjà fixer de petits objectifs qui
nous aide à atteindre ses grands
objectifs il faut avoir des objectifs
pour l'année
il faut avoir des objectifs pour le mois
il faut avoir des objectifs pour la
semaine il faut avoir des objectifs pour
la journée il faut avoir des objectifs
pour l'or et keven qui voulait prendre
des images pour mobiliser le monde pour
sauver le soudan de la famille avait
sous ses yeux l'objectif de l'heure pour
sauver le soudan la famine il faut
empêcher cette jeune fille de mourir de
faim très souvent veut sauter les étapes
on veut sauver le monde quand on n'est
même pas capable de sauver notre propre
monde le poids 2 capable d'atteindre ses
objectifs
une seule chose que je dis très souvent
à mes amis
il faut investir en soi en réalité le
premier investissement de notre honneur
pour ma petite expérience que jésus
c'est l'investissement soit le diplômé
en marketing
aujourd'hui entrepreneur dans le secteur
agricole
c'est un non pas qu à un moment donné il
faut retourner à l'école il faut se
former
il faut lire il fallait bien deux livres
par mois
vingt quatre livres l'année regarder des
vidéos suivre fréquenté toutes les
conférences qui se présentait sur notre
passage
l'investissement en soit c'est la chose
la plus importante que pouvait faire
dans votre vie de tous les jours pascal
réalité lorsque vous êtes bien formés
lorsque vous devenir que la personne de
référence c'est le monde qui viendra
vous en juillet 2015
j'adore tenu une bourse pour l'inde
le parti poursuivre mes études j'avais
ferme à part dire j'avais besoin d'une
chute chose est ce que ma famille devait
apporter comme la contribution c'était
de payer le billet d'avion pour aller en
inde
ma mère s'est battu mon père fait ce
qu'il pouvait mais c'était difficile je
pense que c'est injuste 850 mille francs
réunion on n'a pas pu en 2018
je suis allée d'ivoire en dehors de
l'afrique sans jamais avoir payé un seul
billet d'avion parce que pendant les
trois années qui ont suivi 2015 j'ai
plus le temps d'investir moi je me
rappelle lorsque j'avais ma première
invitation septembre 2016 pour partie au
sénégal à un rassemblement de l'âme de
la bad où on devait on devait parler
d'agriculture que j'ai dit à ma mère que
je parte en au sénégal elle m'a dit mais
j'ai pas d'argent encore pour te payer
le biais je lui ai dire on m'avait payé
le billet elle n'y croyait pas
jusqu'à ce qu' elle ne voit prendre ma
valise et prendre le chemin de
l'aéroport
si vous investissez en vo et que vous
devenez la meilleure personne que vous
devez être c'est le monde qui viendra
vous
ensuite il faut être entre temps être
constant c'est de pouvoir faire la
différence entre le mouvement et le
progrès c'est un mot d'une fatigue
en réalité je connais beaucoup de jeunes
qui sont en mouvement être mouvement va
être dispersée être mouvement s'est fait
plusieurs choses à la fois être en
mouvement c'est un moment donné j'ai un
montant qui me disait daniel fait juste
que tu tu en train de faire il faut te
concentrer sur ça c'est ce qui importe à
me le disait tout le temps je ne
comprenais pas au départ déjà fini par
comprendre
lundi qu'ils entreprenaient dans le
numérique le m'a dit que dans
l'agriculture que le vendredi que dans
la politique le samedi tué à la société
civile
finalement on ne sait pas ce qu'on fait
au juste si vous voulez avoir de
l'impact
il faut être constant et c'est la
constance qui vous permet de vous
améliorer devons peaufiner de devenir
l'espère le secteur d'activité depuis
octobre 2018
je fais partie d'un groupe de jeunes
européens africains consultant auprès de
l'union européenne union africaine ont
travaillé avec auprès de ces deux
institutions sur la question de
l'autonomisation des jeunes dans le
secteur agricole
et quand je le courir pour notre premier
séjour à l'union africaine pour discuter
avec le pôle en charge ces questions
pendant un mois sur la thématique
mon père me disait tu es arrivé c'était
pour la première fois que mon père m'a
dit qu'il était fier de moi mais ça
simplement parce qu'on a accepté
d'investir en nous est d'être constant
la dernière chose que j'ai envie de
partager avec vous c'est ce que
j'appelle avoir de l'impact est pour moi
je vais vous dire une phrase qui va
peut-être vos suppose lorsque moi j'ai
entendu à l'époque j'étais assez surpris
c'est que
la seule chance était que vous pouvez
faire de votre vie c'est d'aider les
autres n'avaient pas conclu
quand j'étais tout jeune déjà accompagné
mon père souvent au chant au village
pendant les vacances et mon père et moi
nous nous rendions dans notre cochon et
avant d'arriver dans notre champ il ya
le voisin de la famille qui avait son
champ de riz donc les angles sont des
voisins c'est comme ça au village est
arrivé dans le champ du voisin qu'on dit
passé avant d'atteindre notre champ mon
père a marqué une pause et je les ai vus
en train de désherber dans le champ du
voisin et il a fait quelques minutes et
j'attire l'attention du fait que ne sont
pas encore dans notre champ et mon père
je me dis qu il le fait parce qu'il est
méchant tu aimes le voisin à sauver sa
récolte et tu me dis que tu le fais
parce que tu es méchant
il m'a dit que j'étais trop jeune et que
je pouvais pas contrôler des années
après on nous étions encore en discuter
et je le rappelle nous passions à gauche
aujourd'hui j'ai relaté la même histoire
et mon père me dire écoute mon fils
searle en récolte de voisins n'est pas
sauver ses enfants viendront quémander
le peu que je vais vous donner à la
maison
et donc pour lui la seule façon de
sécuriser le peu qu'il a à nous donner
était d'aider le voisin avoir de quoi
manger chez lui c'était fort c'était mon
premier mentor mon père depuis que j'ai
choisi de me lancer dans le secteur
agricole mon père ne l'avait pas sept au
départ est l'une des personnes qui
m'avaient accompagné sur ce chemin qui
croyaient en moi qui malgré tout c'était
ma mère
1 elle est maintenant ouest du pays mais
je souhaitais qu'elle soit là ce soir
parce qu'on ne sait pas vraiment ce que
je fais aujourd'hui je voulais saluer ma
mère et lui dit merci d'être là
[Applaudissements]
vous faisiez ma présentation je vais
partager avec faut une toute petite
histoire de moins d'une minute
il y avait un ami qui à faire la cour à
une jeune femme qu'il aimait bien
elles étaient difficiles mais il a mis
du temps à la converse
elle a fini par ces petits c'était
l'amour parfait mais il savait que cet
ami était un peu par essieu et le moment
donné la jeune fille en avait marre
parce que les conditions de la vie rct
pas que ça et elle a décidé de le
quitter parce qu'il n'avait pas
suffisamment de ressources et le sens
plénière
et c'était tellement devenu une histoire
les boisés en traitant cette jeune fille
de matérialiste et quelqu'un la voisine
une voisine de près de là où je réside a
dit quelque chose qui m'a marqué je vais
vous le dis ce soir
vous savez ce qu'elle a dit sylla si
cette femme parler c'est parce que tu
n'as pas l'argent va chercher l'argent
chez un ami ne déplaçons pas le problème
faut résoudre le problème
très souvent nous déplaçons les
problèmes nous accusons les autres
d'être responsable de ce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui de ce que nous vivons et
nous oublions que lorsque nous ne
trouvons pas la solution c'est que le
problème ces nouvelles je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]